and another person
trump appointee out there conning more
people this week
an inspector general appointed by donald
trump
came out this week saying that they did
a thorough investigation
and it turns out that the ppe problems
that america had in the early days of
the pandemic which seems like
centuries ago at this point those ppe
issues it wasn't the fault of the
administration
or the coronavirus task force that he
had put together no
siree it was fema it was all
totally fema uh homeland security
inspector general joseph kufari came out
and said this
the magnitude of the global event
exposed weaknesses in fema's resource
request system and allocation processes
specifically web eoc the system fema
used to
process ppe and ventilator resource
requests
contained unreliable data to inform
allocation decisions
and ensure requests were accurately
adjudicated
in addition although fema developed a
process to allocate the limited supply
of ventilators it did not
have a similar process for ppe there it
is folks case closed according to mr
kufari
fema fema's to blame for how horrible
things were in the early days of the
pandemic
what i love about this is that this is
complete history erasure
we remember how things worked at that
time
you had jared kushner in charge of
ppe and that didn't work out so well
you had ppe that was being taken from
some hospitals
put over in these other places where
trump and his little coronavirus task
force
would then decide how to allocate it
they were taking
things from fema not letting fema do
what they were supposed to
we all know that those reports were
everywhere
this this is just mind-blowing and
sometimes
you get a story like this that just
shakes you to your core
because you know how false it is because
folks
we all lived through this i know i said
it feels like centuries ago
but i'm hoping the more i say these
things it jogs your memory and
everybody's like
oh wait yeah i do remember that this was
crazy times
it was the wild wild west of ppe with
our own government
acting as the bandits taking it from
these places
and reallocating it based on where they
felt
it needed to go for example in the early
days of the pandemic
new york was getting hit harder than
anybody florida was actually doing
pretty well
and this was you know march april 2020
folks
but still they were sending all this ppe
all these ventilators down to the state
of florida
and we had more than we could ever need
down here
meanwhile new york was having to put
people in hospital beds in
parking garages without ventilators
because they just had nothing and they
were getting nothing
and the difference is obviously new york
had a democratic governor
florida had a trump-loving republican
governor it's
really not that hard to put the pieces
together
and yet here you have this report from
kufari coming out and saying nope
coronavirus task force they did
everything right
fema screwed up because their computer
systems were stupid
now i'm not trying to absolve fema of
any you know
any problems that they had during the
painting because sure they had plenty
everybody had plenty we weren't prepared
for this
we had been cutting pandemic funding we
had been cutting preparedness
the trump administration completely
ignored
a response plan that the obama
administration had put in place we had
some protocols
certainly not even enough but we didn't
even follow those
so it is what it is coveted ran rampant
still is rampant is mutating
at an alarming rate at this point we're
now getting reports out this week
that the lambda variant and i think
whichever one is after that
the other variant they mentioned they
think those might actually be vaccine
resistant
and if that is the case we're back to
square one folks
we would be back to lockdowns we would
be back to stay-at-home orders
mask mandates all of that from the
beginning because our vaccines
would be useless against new variants
it is what it is you know we we've we've
elected
crazily and competent people
and we're reaping the uh repercussions
of that
and it's terrifying and yes it's unfair
to the people who didn't vote for all of
these incompetent buffoons
but nevertheless every election can have
nationwide consequences
you know you may not live in florida you
may not have had the chance to vote
against ron desantis
like i did but his idiotic decisions
letting covid run rampant here
are still going to affect you where you
are because the more we have it here
the more it mutates the more it travels
same thing with abbott over in texas
same thing with hutchinson and arkansas
and ivy in alabama and all of these
other southern states where it's blowing
up
it's going to make it back to the blue
states it's going to make it to the west
coast it's going to make it to the
you know midwest
all of these decisions from all of these
politicians big and small
local and national they all affect
each and every one of us
fema screwed up in the beginning the
white house coronavirus task force
screwed up even worse than that
trump screwed up governor screwed up
democratic and republic
uh republican governors hid covet data
cuomo and desantis i'm looking at you
both
and and we're still stuck in it and as i
mentioned we may be back to square one
really soon but hey
i appreciate you tuning in today and i
appreciate david pakman
and everybody else at the david pakman
show for letting me fill in
again i am farren cousins you can get me
on twitter
instagram facebook at fair and balanced
youtube.com
the ring of fire and my personal youtube
youtube.com
slash farron balanced thanks for
watching and stay tuned for today's
bonus show